and finally new rule now that the 25th
amendment
the one about removing a president who's
incapacitated
keeps popping up in the news someone has
to explain to me
if it was written specifically for this
guy then who
is it for
according to bob woodward's book trump's
lawyers told robert mueller that trump
could not testify because he was
incapable of telling the truth
this is what slingblade's lawyer argues
when he's
when he's accused of murder my client is
incompetent to stand trial
now i know everyone by now knows that
trump is a narcissist
but we have to stop treating that like
it's an unfortunate
personality tick and start treating it
like what it is
a serious and dangerous mental illness
trump
trump likes to tag everything within
history
he did it again this week we have the
greatest economy ever in the history of
our country
it's always [ __ ] but in this one
area he
really might be the most extreme case of
narcissistic
personality disorder in history
nixon was bad at the end he was talking
to the white house paintings
but trump thinks the paintings are
talking to him
when trump masturbates he fantasizes
about himself masturbating
this isn't a quirk like having a fear of
clowns
or calling your wife mommy
it's in the big book of crazy
trump sets off a hundred bombs a week
and we chase all of them but
all his flaws are really outgrowths of
one thing if there was a nutrition label
on his ass it would
it would say 35 fat 65
narcissistic personality disorders
it all comes from that narcissism is why
he has no empathy
his first thought after the planes hit
the towers on 9 11 was
now my building is the tallest
his whole life is the old joke about the
doctor who tells his patient i've got
good news and bad news
the bad news you only got a week to live
the good news
you see my nurse i'm banging her
it's an old joke you'll get over it
narcissism is why trump can be a traitor
and think he's a patriot
because it's like what jfk said ask not
what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for me narcissism is
why our government
is now so corrupt because the only
quality that matters
is being an unbearable suck ass to trump
no president has ever consulted more
widely
or talked with more people from more
backgrounds
to seek input about a supreme court
nomination
oh please you had him at presidents
cannot be prosecuted
no
narcissism is why we have a foreign
policy based
entirely on whether or not when our
leader meets your leader
he thinks they like him he said about
president g
i like him and i believe he likes me a
lot
oh i hope so
maybe you guys can watch the notebook
together and braid each other's hair
same thing with putin he said i hope i
like him i hope he likes me
and then there's his buddy in north
korea i just came
on stage and i was told that kim jong-un
said some terrific things about me
great maybe he'll sign your tits
that's all you got to do is say
something nice donald trump
is the world's cheapest date he likes me
i like him
who knows what's gonna happen
like what you're gonna [ __ ]
who cares whether other heads of state
like ours
these other leaders are laughing at him
as if putin's in the kremlin going oh i
hope he likes me
i would poison myself if i thought
donald trump didn't like me
take selfie of me i send it to trump
and most chillingly narcissism
is why trump is so stupid the president
of the united states
the planet's most powerful human in a
data-driven world
full of shifting information can never
learn
anything narcissism makes you
unteachable
you can't correct him because that would
mean he was wrong
and that's impossible he's infallible
like the pope or oprah
trump's brain is like a cell phone with
a full mailbox
you can call but you can't leave a
message